now I used to be content with that but
then it occurred to me recently that
this is one of those fantastic theorems
or properties where the converse is true
so if I were to reverse the logic here
if in fact I said to you rather than
saying oh I know that this is the
diameter that means that this is going
to be 90 degrees can my logic go in the
opposite direction can I say if I know
that this is 90 degrees therefore that A
B has to be a diameter now it turns out
that this is true and I've taught that
it is true for like I said many years
but it occurred to me that I'd never
proven that for students I'd never
actually shown the result and the the
reasoning behind it and it's super
important to actually recognize why
things are true and not just accept them
right
not just because in mathematics that's
one of the great things you can do you
can prove things you don't need to
accept some you know to take someone
else's word for it you can actually
prove it yourself rigorously but also
just in general it's a logical fallacy
that a leads to B also is the same as B
leads to a the converse is not always
true let me give you a couple of really
obvious examples
suppose I told you you had a
quadrilateral of some kind and that
quadrilateral was a square so if you
know that this is a square one of the
things that you can conclude about it is
that all of its sides are going to be
equal so in other words the logic here
is knowing that something is a square
tells you that you can deduce that that
all sides are equal
now that's fine that is a very logically
sound statement but it doesn't work in
the other direction it's it's Converse
is not necessarily true if you again
take the idea that there is some
quadrilateral and I say well instead of
knowing that it's a square let me just
tell you that all the sides of this
mystery quadrilateral are equal does
that necessarily mean that you have a
square and the answer is of course not
because what you might have is something
like this see how accurately I can do it
oh not very accurately at all let's see
better well let's let's shift that and
make that a little more accurate I think
that's pretty reasonable looking so what
I've got here is a side where uh sorry a
quadrilateral wear all the sides are
equal but in fact it is clearly not a
square I guess we would just call this a
rhombus right so what I'm trying to
point out here is that the converse just
reversing the statements and seeing what
happens to the logical flow is not
actually true I mean it might be you
know if you put all the right angles in
you will get a square but it isn't
always right so logic can go from one
side to the other but not flow in the
opposite direction now you might think
oh that's pretty obvious like it doesn't
need to really be said but there are
some cases where it's not as obvious for
example I'm not going to do this to
scale but you get the idea suppose I
gave you I presented you with three
parallel lines and I said okay here here
are three lines
and uh I I'm going to uh mark them as
parallel and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to slice across them with
two transversals right so if I have a
transversal say here
and then I have another one put it over
in this direction okay so these
transversals just literally cut across
that's what the word transversal means
my parallel lines now supposing you had
some measurements if say for example you
measured
this uh little interval here to be two
this one here is the one that I'm
talking about and then you measure this
one and found that it was four it was
double that length what these links are
called by the way these are what we call
intercepts which is sort of confusing
because you're like wait a second I
thought intercepts were like coordinates
in coordinate geometry that are where
things intersect together the
overlapping meaning is that they come
from an intersection but in this context
the intercepts are actually the lengths
themselves that I've highlighted here in
blue and in Orange okay
now uh there is a theorem that says if
you have parallel lines what they do is
they preserve the ratios between the
intercepts uh by which I mean if say for
example you measure this intercept over
here as three so it's kind of up between
these two parallel lines at the top then
you could know without even measuring it
that this intercept down here would have
the same ratio as the other intercept so
you can see here this is this orange
length I've just made it double the blue
length up here and so this orange length
over here is also going to be double its
corresponding intercept so the way I
would say this is
uh parallel lines preserve the ratios of
intercepts so in here the logic runs
like so parallel lines
gives you uh equal ratio intercepts
that's not very good grammar but you get
the idea
okay now again in this case and I gave
you this example before right this is
another important instance of where the
converse is not true it feels like it
ought to be it feels intuitive that if
you got equal ratio intercepts then
maybe that also means that you will have
that same set of parallel lines but it's
not true and I can really easily show
you that with a counter example suppose
I have three lines now that are
definitely definitely not parallel so if
I have one flying off in this direction
and then one down here okay so I think
it's fairly uncontroversial that these
three lines are not parallel but now if
I cut across them with an appropriately
placed pair of transversals like so
something like this right
if I compare here right I can say hey
look at this intercept and compare it to
this one suppose that these were both
equal
to three
if I have a look at the other pair and
I'm just suppose I'm just doing
measurements right I look at this one
and then I have a look at this one well
just eyeballing it it wouldn't be that
difficult to create a set of intercepts
like this where this was five and this
was five so in other words what I have
is uh intercepts with equal ratios this
is a one-to-one ratio and so is this one
but that doesn't mean you can't deduce
from that that the three lines I started
with are parallel they're quite
obviously not so in this case
just taking these ideas over here if I
were to swap around you know try and
reverse the direction of The Logical
flow
it turns out to not be true that equal
ratio intercepts mean there are parallel
lines and this is an example where I had
to kind of manufacture a counter example
that made it very obvious but it
wouldn't be as obvious as this Square
rhombus thing right so what I'm trying
to say is when you know something is
true you have to be really careful with
the converse it is sometimes true
um Pythagoras's Theorem you know if you
know that it's right angled you'll get
that some of the squares on each of the
different sides and the reverse is true
if you know the sums of the squares and
so on you can prove that a triangle is
right angled and in this case right I'm
about to prove that if uh you know that
that angle uh on the circumference is 90
degrees you can know that the chord that
produced that angle or created that
angle is going to be the diameter it has
to be the diameter I can prove that that
Converse is true but you shouldn't just
assume it right